my brother died when I was nine years
old he looked me in the eye and said I
will never leave you he was going hiking
the Grand Tetons and he said I'll never
leave you I'm coming back I'm like
please don't go away I don't like it
when you're gone I was the youngest he
was the oldest there were six of us and
we were a team like we were a sports
team and you know he promised he would
come back and he didn't and my life from
that moment on was about not believing
anybody ever again because you couldn't
rely on a person ever again it was my
first boyfriend it was my first crush he
was everything you you never been in
touch with the anger that your brother
betrayed you for leaving you by dying
right I thought that was rejection
because I was nine I took it as oh he
found another little sister that he
likes better a better family not that he
died in a terrible accident talk to me
about that because you write about it in
your book I mean that's that's
tremendously painful obviously and that
helped you get in touch with why you
were so angry it was really directed
more at your brother for abandoning you
for leaving you from this world he
wasn't supposed to do that you were
super close to this brother yeah was it
painful to write about was it difficult
to write about it it was difficult to to
get out like you know like look at me
now I can't talk about it without
getting emotional but at least I'm now I
know that that's okay to be emotional
like you don't have to fight crying and
so I thought being vulnerable for so
long because you know he died then my
dad basically theoretically died after
that my dad was never the same after my
brother died so the two men whose center
of attention I had been you know I'd
been pulled out from under me and I and
I never had a time to really unwrap that
I never went to therapy about it you
never really talked it out I was really
really really angry at my brother for
dying until I somebody told me and then
I could identify it
I had no it's so easy for you to look at
me and say okay this is what happened
your brother died this is your problem
but you've got to connect that this
isn't why you can't this is why you
can't have a healthy relationship that's
why you don't trust man this is why I
have to be so fierce so independent I
don't need you I don't need anybody if I
can do everything on my own because even
when I would talk to you off the air
about men and stuff you just seemed
pissed off with men like I didn't I
didn't see how you could be in a good
relationship because you were just too
[ __ ] angry with it
buddy right so now maybe you're ready
for the big relation I am I think I am
and I think the big the key to that is
actually not feeling like a whiny little
[ __ ] by saying I do want to be in a
relationship I would love that now I
feel healthy I feel like I understand
what my shortcomings are and I do want
to be in a relationship and for a
longest time I thought that was so weak
to admit